Seriously North Korea, another underground
nuclear test?
You know we can see you, right?
[DNEWS OPEN]
[MAIN]
Hey hermit kings and queens, Trace here for
DNews.
So the Democratic People’s Republic of Korea,
AKA North Korea, has reportedly tested their
5th nuclear device.
They want us to know they did it.
We know they want us to know they did it.
And they know that we know that they want
us to know what we know.
But how can we know it was a nuclear bomb?
We’re not just going to take Kim Jong-un’s
word for it.
There’s actually an organization called
the Preparatory Commission for the Comprehensive
Nuclear-Test-Ban Treaty Organization.
Or the CTBTO…
Though technically I guess it should be the
PCCNTBTO.
Since 1996, the CTBTO has had it’s ear to
the ground around the world, listening for
any rumblings.
That’s not just a metaphor, they literally
have 42 primary and 107 secondary stations
around the world monitoring seismic activity.
Usually they just pick up earthquakes, but
if there’s a nuclear test underground, like
all the North Korean ones have been, they’ll
pick up the seismic waves through the earth’s
crust and mantle.
Based on the direction, speed and type of
waves each station picks up, the location
of the test site can be deduced.
But what if the tests are conducted underwater?
That scenario has been planned for too, and
the CTBTO has an array of 10 hydroacoustic
monitoring stations globally.
Why only 10?
Because sound travels amazingly well under
water, particularly 1000 meters down, at a
depth known as the Sound Fixing and Ranging
channel, or SOFAR.
With just a handful of stations, they can
still hear nuclear tests in the earth’s
oceans, even when they’re SOFAR away…
Get it?
And if the tests are conducted in the atmosphere,
the CTBTO can catch that too.
Again the method is to use sound, this time
at frequencies so low we can’t even hear
them, or infrasound.
These longer wavelengths travel farther but
they still don’t move as efficiently as
sound in water, so there are 49 infrasound
stations in use right now to listen to the
breeze.
As a bonus, underground tests generate infrasound
too, so the data can be combined with the
seismographs for more accurate information.
You’ll notice all these methods of detection
have something in common: they can be tripped
by non-nuclear means.
Volcanoes, earthquakes, and conventional explosions
can cause seismic activity and sound waves.
There’s only one
way to know for sure the bomb was an A Bomb:
radioactive fallout. When a nuclear bomb explodes,
it creates radioactive xenon isotopes. And,
because xenon is a gas, it can seep through
layers of rock until it reaches the open air.
This means that unless tests are conducted
deep underwater or underground, the CTBTO
can forensically prove when someone tests
a nuclear bomb.
So then what? Well that’s where the bulldog
loses its teeth, I’m afraid. The Comprehensive
Test Ban Treaty has been signed and ratified
by 164 countries but still needs 8 more before
it can enter into force. Hence why the organization
is still technically called the “Preparatory
Commission” for the CTBTO. So currently
when a country sets off a bomb, all the rest
of the world can really do is wag a finger
at it and impose more sanctions for the test
that was unsanctioned. North Korea, perhaps
unsurprisingly, has not signed or ratified
the treaty, but to be fair the USA has signed
it but hasn’t ratified it either. Still,
until every country is on the same page about
nuclear weapons, at least the CTBTO has the
tools to warn the rest of the world that someone’s
not being chill.
Guys, if you love DNews in English -- gracias! Now, we've got a new sister
show, "DNews en Español" -- It's DNews, but
in Spanish! Check it out here.
In early 2015 North Korea set off what they
claimed was a hydrogen bomb, but was it? How
is an H bomb even different from an A bomb?
Julian covers all that here.
What’s your stance on nuclear weapons? Inexcusable
superweapon or necessary evil?
Let us know in the comments, make sure you subscribe,
So you get more DNews and thanks for watching.